second they're saying well my husband  you've never been in a mature  relationship guys keep your beta  husbands with no backbone i don't want  them  i want a guy that would stand up for  himself  do i want a guy that would be okay with  me getting morbidly obese  no keep your damn husbands  bro okay  um let me look at what else  okay then another person commented i  don't want my future daughter seeing  this man what's what's meaner to your  daughter  getting morbidly obese like that is the  meanest thing you can do to a kid is  raise them in a household with habits  that make them obese and i know this  because before my mom lost all the  weight i was that kid  that had those horrible eating habits  and half the reason i'm motivated to  stay in shape and like get better with  this stuff  is because i want to raise a family and  i don't want  my kids to struggle with weight